[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in lewis riddick
of the monday night football analyst
former pro scout director of pro
personnel and of course a former
nfl defensive back who joins us on the
program lewis thanks for joining us
was that a dirty hit on patrick mahomes
in your opinion by mac wilson
no it really didn't it didn't come off
that way to me watching it live
and you know having watched mac wilson
play and and
you know and anecdotally just kind of
like seeing what other people have said
about mack wilson and
how matt kind of expressed you know his
feelings afterwards
it didn't seem like that quite honestly
damn when i saw the hit
you know i'm sitting there thinking wow
where where did it come from i mean how
did he get
how did he concuss on this play because
it wasn't a vicious style it wasn't like
the same kind of hit like the deviant
put on um
uh put on carson wentz in the playoff
game a year ago it wasn't that same kind
of
you know hit to the back of the head so
i mean i i was i was kind of shocked
quite honestly when
patrick got up looking the way that he
did but um
you know from all indications based on
what andy said he was doing well after
the game and hopefully he can play next
week
well i thought sorensen's hit on higgins
helmet to helmet was far more egregious
and that was not called
absolutely i mean no question about that
and i think that's something that
that the league and the referees are
going to have to be more consistent
about and continue to work to try and be
more consistent
because look i mean nick clearly dropped
his head
clearly hit higgins in the side of the
head i mean it was
i mean it's as plain as day and
although that's not reviewable i mean
it's just it's it's wild that that is
not
that that's not being called with more
consistency and i understand it's a big
game and it's a crucial play and you
don't want to
you don't have crucial plays like that
in ball games decided by ref
you know referee calls and flags being
put on the field but
in the name of safety which is always
what this has always been about
you have to strive for more consistency
than that what do you think of the rule
where you do
you fumble the ball out of the end zone
and automatically you know the defense
it you turn it over to the defense
yeah i think i'm like unlike everyone
else i mean you don't
it seems very ridiculous that you know
and
that you're being punished for effort
for trying to score
the football and you know and then you
lose possession of the football totally
at that point in time
and you know you don't have another
chance to try and punch it in
i mean with the rule being what it is i
mean you've heard many coaches
you know bill belichick in particular
and i know kevin stefanski
was talking about it as well coach
players to not reach the ball out unless
you were sure
unless you know you're able to score
don't do it which you're never going to
know if you're able
not you know to score per se and it
sucks because it's one of those plays
that really kind of took the wind out of
uh out of the sales of the browns at
that point in time
but i'm sure they're gonna look at it
here in the off season because you just
don't you don't want those kind of
things again
coming up in big games dan deciding
football games or deciding the momentum
or
you know significantly uh swinging the
momentum of football games but how would
you fix the rule
i think you know at the
that's hard to say i mean i think
there's a there's a number of different
ways that you could
i think at that point in time
you know i i don't i don't really know i
don't really know because i said just
take it back to the 25 yard line
loss of down and yeah and then that way
i'm going to punish you but i'm not
going to punish you for
that extra effort i i it i can't
decimate you for something like that
although i do agree with what belichick
and mike grebel say to their players
just don't do it right but i'm thinking
if we change the rule how do we change
the rule and maybe you just bring it
back to the 25-yard line
yeah i mean that that's that sounds like
a you know a pretty standard way to try
and
legislate that kind of play you know as
far as
legislating some kind of action or some
kind of punishment
it's it's hard i you know i haven't
really thought it through about how
exactly would you fix it although
it just seems way too punitive obviously
to take the ball away from the offense
again in punishing effort like that
i'd have to give more thought to exactly
what you know how to do that and i think
the league's going to have to too and i
think that's why the rule hasn't been
changed because they probably haven't
been able to think about what
exactly what do you change it to then
what makes the most sense in that kind
of situation
as a former defensive back i want you to
put yourself
in the defense yesterday with the browns
when you see chad henny
and it's fourth down and you see the
play clock
they're gonna try to draw you off sides
you don't think that
chad henny is going to run a play given
where the ball is and what's at stake
here
what do you think as a defensive player
in a situation like that and the
possibility of them running a play
yeah as a second level defender in
particular dan and you're not on the on
the defensive line obviously if you're
if you're a d-lineman i think first and
foremost you're thinking number one i'm
just not jumping off sides i'm not
moving till this ball moves even if i'm
laid off the football so i think
their mindset is much different than the
second and third level defenders if
you're a linebacker of safety
you're off the ball anyway so you don't
really care about hard count you're not
it's not going to really affect you one
way or another what you need to be
focused in on is
in the event that they do run a play i
need to know where i need to be
and i know it's particularly where i
need to be in regards to who their best
players are
so i definitely needed to know where
number 10 was i needed to know where
tyrique was going to be
and you can't relax in that type of
situation and then lastly
with fourth and one type situations
you're sitting there in the shotgun
i mean that's more from a coaching
standpoint you just have to like
like sprint right option is something
that andy reid and all west coast
offenses
have run over and over again that's
that's all that play was that's what
they were running back in the days of
bill walsh and
i mean it seems it sounds easier you
know easier said than done at this point
in time
but i think that that's what it's all
that's what it's about on the
professional level
it's about preparation it's about key
moments like that
and you just have to be prepared for you
can't get caught off guard
you just can't i know everyone from from
from romo to the people sitting at home
were shocked that they actually ran the
play
but again if you're a second or third
level defender you're a linebacker
safety corner
and it's about doing your job and not
worrying about whether or not they're
just gonna try and draw the
you know the front four or front five
offside
and then it's just too bad it's too bad
that if in fact people
did relax and weren't really playing
with the same kind of uh
urgency that they normally would that it
ultimately cost them because
that was a huge freaking play it was a
huge play
is lewis redick the espn monday night
football analyst
of the four losing teams over this
weekend who's in
the best shape moving forward
wow you know
really i mean i i would say look the the
browns are
i think the browns are in good shape
because kevin really does have a good
idea of what
he wants his football team to look like
him for the first time in a long time
he's got them
pointed in the right direction and
andrew barry has done a fantastic job of
continuing some of the work
that they have done previously as far as
stockpiling draft picks and drafting
young players so i think they're in good
shape
from an afc standpoint and and look i
think baltimore is too
on the on the nfc side i think the rams
the rams got to figure out exactly what
it is that that they really
feel towards jared goff and if he is
going to be the guy for the future for
them moving forward
and because it just sounds like shawn at
this point in time is just non-committal
and that he's really going to take a
deep dive hard look at his football team
particularly at that position but from
from a young player's standpoint they
have done a pretty darn good job
under some difficult circumstances given
what they've given up in terms of draft
capital to get some of the players that
they have
of still stockpiling that roster
and positioning themselves for the
future here in in one of the toughest
divisions in football
if not the toughest division and
football ultimately out there in the nfc
west so
i think those two teams in particular
look real good
going forward i mean the saints have a
lot a lot of issues going i mean
they are just in absolute cap hell going
forward
they got to figure out what's going on
at quarterback now because you you have
to assume that drew's last game was last
night
is james the guy is tasting the guy
what's the situation there
and how they're going to continue to
build out this roster given the fact
that
they're going to have such limited
resources from the sorry cap uh
sorry cavern perspective
would you rather go against aaron
rodgers or
tom brady
there's no third option there by the way
yeah you know what i mean i i think
i mean that's so man either way man i'm
to be i'm going to be disrespecting to
the greats but i think
right now i mean i'd i'd rather go
against tom
because of the fact that i think tom has
his own reasons
for wanting to continue to be great and
obviously get to the super bowl and the
guy has never become complacent despite
the fact that he's been
the most successful individual probably
in team sports maybe in
well definitely in the history of the
nfl but aaron
aaron's just on a different he's on a
different level
and has a mindset in a in a cockiness in
a
in kind of a way about him right now
that having talked to them both this
year
on monday night uh production calls but
you just
knew that he was going to continue to
try and just absolutely
torch everyone all year long and
he he was he was in a zone with
with matt lafleur that maybe he's never
ever been
in his entire career and that's saying
something given some of the spectacular
seasons that he that he's had
but can we simplify this low lewis and
say
when the packers drafted jordan love
they lit a fire
in aaron rodgers um
well we can try to although if you if
you ask him
and when you talk to him he won't say it
lit a fire
although you you know it did to some
degree i mean because you know them he's
just one of the
he's a type a competitor i i just think
he hit
a level in his second year in the off
season
in terms of his relationship with matt
that this was inevitable whether or not
they drafted jordan or not
i think this this the evolution in terms
of his comfort in that offense was going
to happen dan no matter what
i would draft a quarterback in this
year's draft
yeah i mean you know i mean there's no
doubt that you know look
he's he's again given all no matter how
successful he's been and that's the cool
thing about all these guys
all these guys who are supreme supreme
achievers
they i mean just like the jordan like we
saw with jordan in the last dance they
always were looking for something and
even though they won't admit it
of course it drives them but i think
that relationship and i'm a big look i'm
big on that part of it
and the importance of relationships as
he developed that relationship with matt
laporton offseason and matt talked about
that too
this thing just took off man i mean it
just took off and you see
you see it happening with time right now
as him and bruce get more comfortable as
him and byron get more comfortable in
tampa bay they
look like they are starting to click and
they really did last night
now is it going to be enough against
green bay i mean you know you've been up
there
you know how miserable it is up there
and aaron has talked about it how much
are you willing to suffer
when you come to lambeau how much are
you how much can you take
how soon until you start looking at the
clock going hey those buses right
outside the stadium heat them up man
i'm going to get the hell out of here
that's what he says it says it's it's
how long are you willing to suffer
and we're going to find out next week as
far as tampa is concerned
uh let's see what else did i have oh
how do you salvage deshawn watson
you know i was just asking this a little
while ago i don't know
i mean you know how relationships are
sometimes it's not salvageable
sometimes you just breach someone's
trust
so so much to the point where there is
no turning back
there just isn't and this sounds so
systemic down there and so ingrained
in the way not only he feels but other
players feel too
that i don't know if you do i i don't i
just don't know if you if you do
and that would be a damn shame to be
honest with you but you start
taking offers though lewis what's that
you start taking offers
i think you have to listen because if
the guy doesn't want to play and you and
he has a no trade clause and you can't
dictate to him where you send them to
and what are you going to do
what are you going to do and they're
they're in a terrible situation from a
team rebuild as far as not having draft
capital
and they could get a boat load of it and
there's teams out there who have a boat
load of it to offer them
now that would be a terrible way to
start off your your
you know your tenure down there if
you're nick casario
but hey if you're nick you're you're
like hey look i'm not the one who
created this situation
i'm not the one who directly created
this situation but i'm going to try and
make the best of it
because it may be one of those then you
can't recover and if you listen to
deshawn
and you talk to people who have been
down there and it's not just deshawn
who's feeling this way he's just the
front-facing guy he's just the one
god forbid i'll tell you what if jj y
comes out and says something like this
too to the point where he says look i
just want out of here i want to end my
time here
because the wheels are going to really
come off well he's going to yeah
yeah he's not going to play there next
year i can't see no jj playing there
uh and also i i was told this two weeks
ago by source
don't be surprised if eric b enemy does
not get a head coaching job
now there's two openings louis what am i
missing here with eric the enemy
and it looks like leslie frazier might
be the leading candidate with houston
and then we have philadelphia i think
what you have is
look human beings are making these
decisions and human beings engage in
confirmation bias
all all the time and right now for some
reason
and i don't really want to go down this
rabbit hole to the point where you know
we make this into a racial discussion
but for some reason
all these things all these different
excuses keep coming up about
eric whether it be he doesn't interview
well or are there things in his past
that cause you to press pause
you know in terms of his accountability
and leadership and
and and you know his dependability going
forward which is just bs and andy has
talked about so many different times but
it's just ridiculous to even bring up at
this point but i think
that that's what's happening then of
course there's the whole he doesn't call
plays well
you know what i've talked to andy enough
times about this in brett beach
to say that the amount of responsibility
that they put on him
is is the same if not more than the
responsibility that andy gave to
both doug and um and matt maggie
so i i don't i i would i would
hope like hell that this is not simply
about
you know the whole you know being
comfortable
with hiring people who don't necessarily
look like you have the same experiences
as you and you still have those kind of
hang-ups
and have those kind of reservations that
would keep you from hiring a young coach
like him
a relatively young coach like him who
has coached one of the greatest players
we've seen coming into this league
ever and who vouches for him without
without pause i would hate that that
would i would hope that that is not
something that is deciding this uh
this man's future as far as being a head
coach but i'm not naive enough to think
that
it's not a factor because there's no
other reason
there's no other reason at this point
then there's this flat out no other
reason
and and that's that's awful that's
something i know the commissioner
does not want to be the case i've talked
to the commissioner i know how important
that is to him
and for this to be something that again
we're addressing another
another year another hiring cycle is
this flat out embarrassing and
ridiculous
that we haven't even entertained these
conversations why isn't eric b enemy
at the forefront of someone's you know
someone's uh
hiring wishlist why isn't he not at not
at the top
i'd love to know what those reasons are
those objective reasons are
i would love to have sat in on an
interview with him until
to where people come out of an interview
and go nah he's not quite the guy
and that's not to take anything away
from some of these other guys who are
getting jobs because i tell you this
i said back in september the very first
time i talked to brandon staley
this kid is fantastic he's fantastic
was blown away by him and sean told me
that at the super bowl last year you're
going to be blown away by brandon staley
he is that sharp i've talked to robert
saul
i know how how impressive he is i know
how impressive
he is brian dabo i know how impressive
even though he may not get his
job either in this cycle i know how
impressive these guys are arthur smith
i've known for 15 years
arthur smith used to come and watch tape
with me in washington sitting in the
in the scouting room in the scouting
hallway when he was just trying to
figure out what he wanted to do with his
life
and and vinnie serrado and his dad fred
smith said hey can he just sit in here
and watch film with you because he just
wants to
be around football and now he i knew
arthur was going to be a head coach
so these guys are fantastic but for eric
right now to have the conversations
thrown around him in the manner in which
it is
is just criminal it really is it's it's
sad because i talked to him as well
and probably talked to more people about
him than i've talked to about any of
these guys and it's just
it's just so unfortunate and it's so
defeating and it's so deflating
but onward we must press and
that's just the way it is well said
louis
thank you we appreciate your time thanks
for joining us
absolutely dan thank you louis riddick
from the mothership monday night
football analyst